everyone here grid Ironhide geared up  for the only game that truly matters the  probe again you boys didn't practice for  two whole days to lose this game again  clear eyes full hearts robo coach I got  the boats  I can play son I am so proud of you  you're a pro Paul turn  here's the god football and a 2019 AFC  Pro Bowl team guys my brothers Pam did  you by the way play for the Steelers  nice to meet you hmm the Camping World  Stadium in Orlando Florida doesn't get  much better than this they played a  Citrus Bowl here okay boys we're just  gonna play good old high speed football  with minimal tackling oh I'm so bummed I  can't play in this big game win this for  me son  throw balls and memories that's all you  got best place right you're embarrassing  me code 3 subscribe to this channel and  rot your brain with more episodes  YouTube it's a distraction coach Coach  coach  wait coach coach hey wait coach coach  goes